you can't have Liberty if you don't have
a personal responsible individual and
you can't have pure Liberty if you don't
have people who are mentally tough and
able to compete in a free market all of
these things are intertwined
[Music]
here we are on the Sunday special I'm
excited to welcome congressman Dan
Crenshaw we're gonna be getting to all
of our questions for Dan Crenshaw his
entire life story everything you need to
know about Dan Crenshaw will get you in
just one second first let's talk about
the fact you're gonna die I know it's
it's a downer but getting life insurance
can feel like assembling the world's
worst jigsaw puzzle it is confusing it
takes forever and at the end you die and
when you're finally done it doesn't even
look cool but if you have a mortgage
kids anybody who depends on your income
it is a puzzle you actually need to
solve and policy genius can help you do
it policy genius is the easy way to get
life insurance in just two minutes you
can compare quotes from top insurers and
find the best policy for you when you
apply online the advisors a policy
genius will handle all the red tape for
you they'll even negotiate your rate
with the insurance company no Commission
sales agents no hidden fees just helpful
advice and personalized service and
policy genius doesn't just do life
insurance they also do disability
insurance home insurance auto insurance
their one-stop shop for financial
protection so if you find life insurance
puzzling head on over to policy genius
com in two minutes you can compare
quotes find the right policy and save up
to 40% doing it policy genius.com it's
the easy way to compare and buy life
insurance go check them out right now
they do make policy they make life
insurance and all other sorts of
insurance incredibly easy go check them
out policy genius com the easy way to
compare buy life insurance well
congressman Crenshaw thanks so much for
stopping by thanks for having me well
cool to be here I'm very excited to have
you her a little less excited that I was
before since we arm wrestled which went
very poorly for me before the show yeah
no you're doing really well and then you
weren't this I know you're nice guys for
a short half second I felt a surge of
hope in my heart I wanted to give that
to it that's nice because you were just
bragging about doing Crossfit and I know
this we could have a hundred push-ups no
problem and these are your words not
just idea I'm just these are your words
I mean I say facts don't care about your
feelings but I didn't say they they
don't care about my let's talk about how
you got here
so most people who know you nationwide
know you from the appearance I know so
no but I wanna start before that how did
you get to Congress in the first place
because your story is is really quite
fascinating well the truth is I never
want to leave the Navy so I was wounded
back in 2012 oh and I think people know
this story pretty well by now I was
blown up by 90d blast I my interpreter
was killed right in front of me and I
was blinded and
miraculously recovered to just you know
absolute miracles in the operating room
I did two more deployments after that
not combat-related but back to the
Middle East and and into Korea after
that and eventually the Navy realized
that I couldn't see very well and I had
to go on to a medical retirement track
so I left in late 2016 went to Harvard I
know you think you spent some time there
as well
you know wonderful place and I did my
Master's there and my wife actually both
went in the sense that you know she can
take classes with me was it was it was a
pretty great year and I knew a first of
all Harvard makes everybody think they
can be in politics and being a president
especially at the Kennedy School and and
so in the back of my mind I knew if I
wanted to if I if I wanted to really
have an impact on all of the policy
issues that I care about not just maybe
a singular policy focus that you
eventually have to get in the politics
but how do you do that okay there's
there's three things you really need
rather need to be independently wealthy
you need to have great political
connections or you just need to have a
window of opportunity and so our window
of opportunity came when ted poe
announced retirement it was my home
district and we went for it you know I
came home one day asked my wife should
we do this she goes - yep
it was without hesitation because it has
to be a family it has to be a family
decision and so we went for it we tried
to connect with as many people as we
could
it was kind of this desperate sort of
grassroots campaigning and it and it
worked out we won the primary and we
only a couple months because we made
this decision November the the primaries
in Texas are March 6th so an early
voting starts two weeks before that
mail-in ballots a whole month before
that so you really got to get ahead of
the curve here we got second place in
that election by 155 votes and then we
were off into a runoff and rest is
history so what actually prompted you
get in the military in the first place
we're of the same generation we nearly
same age and very few people of our
generation actually join the military
I'm a good example of this so you did
something that I didn't do so thank you
for that obviously but what prompted you
to get into the military said you want
to be in the Navy and you were a Navy
SEAL obviously so what what made that
happen I read a book when I was maybe
eight years old called a road warrior
and if you talk to most seals this is
just as generally their story because
the only way you really make it through
something like buds is to have wanted it
your entire life there is no choice
for you once you get there doesn't
matter how long I keep you in the
Pacific Ocean doesn't matter how long
they make you run with a boat on your
head or how many law or hours of log PT
you do it just doesn't matter to you
because it's just something you have to
get there you complain about it you
whine about it
but you just have to do it and that's
just our mentality if if you didn't want
that your whole life it's really tough
to have that mentality so I smoked eyes
I know have the same story I did yeah
just childhood dream and we went for it
and what is the buzz program like for I
mean most of us haven't experienced it
obviously it's just an online course
that's right yeah
well it's it's it's it's it's a lot of
fun but it's also quite terrible looking
back on it we have a lot of fond
memories but so it's six months long the
first two months are called first phase
in the second second phase in the third
phase first phase is you're not really
learning anything except how to harden
yourself all right how to push yourself
way past the limits you thought possible
the fourth week of first phase is hell
week okay so you're up for about six
days I broke my leg my first time
through I had to be recycled throughout
the entire program you'd run about 200
miles with these with these with Calm
IBS inflatable both systems basically a
river rafting boat you you boat crew six
takes these everywhere with you you run
about 200 miles throughout the course of
just that week you've been doing it for
about a month second phase is dive phase
you know a lot of control what I would
call controlled drowning you know it's
it's those are some of my least favorite
parts of buds because they're trying to
make you comfortable underwater trying
to make you comfortable in the worst
situations possible at the bottom of the
pool and you get through that you're the
third phase of land warfare phase and
they make that painful and difficult for
all a whole bunch of other sorts of
reasons
and even after buds is over you're not a
seal yet you have to go through what's
called seal qualification train now
you're really learning you're really
honing some skills then you get your
tridents and then you go to a team and
then you go through an entire another
year or so of training with your
platoons that you are a you are a you
are just a really perfect war fighting
machine when you actually deploy it's
amazing so when you decided to join
Congress what were sort of the
ideological goals that you had it's
interesting I have an easy job I gets to
talk about politics all day long I get
to be as pure as I want to be a few
months ago I was supposed to speak on
the hill I suppose
speak actually at Georgetown and they
canceled my speech because there's a big
snow day and so instead I ended up doing
a kind of impromptu session with all the
congressional staffers a couple hundred
congressional staffers showed up and
they were you know talking about how
much they enjoyed the try said well you
guys have the hard job I feel the same
thing about you I mean you you have a
rough job being in Congress means you
have to make deals it means you have to
compromise on principle how is that
shift between being the ideologue who
wants to run for Congress and then
actually sitting in Congress those two
questions which is which is what I ran
on and then and then this broader
question of of how do we probably
maintain that balance which ideological
pure ism and in practicality so I I
tried to run on things that I knew I
could at least fight for you know in an
in a very real way and I ran on border
security I ran on the debt things I
really care about most because of how
old we are right and I believe this is a
melt so I think this is something that
reaches across party lines when speaking
to people our age I've noticed that I I
ran on the third rail of politics you
know entitlement reforms because it's
going to crush our generation it's and
and that actually speaks to a lot of
young people so I talked about that a
lot a lot more than most politicians
think they should and in actually but I
was rewarded for it you know furbish
being honest about these things I ran on
flooding issues they know that's a
unique local issue to Houston it's not
really partisans it doesn't really choir
any kind of purism there but this
broader question and it like you said
and I think we were getting at is you
know how do we deal with conservative
media how do we how do we deal with
people who who only want you to support
the president no matter what and or
support certain ideals no matter what
never vote for anything and then trying
to balance that and into some kind of
practical sense and I think the solution
for politicians is just be open about it
just be open about why you're voting a
certain way like what pressures you had
to face and to get that I think voters
are more willing to listen than a lot of
politicians realize and so I mean just
honesty knowing why you believe what you
believe and knowing and knowing why you
can't quite get there being able to take
that you know win a few yards as opposed
to it's a Hail Mary touchdown I think is
important for us too
but and simultaneously doesn't require
us to let go of those fundamental
principles that drive us there in the
first place so what do you think are the
fundamental principles that drive you
what's your political philosophy what's
your brand of conservatism the I would
say the things that make our our country
sustainable right now I like to put into
very simple terms like that so what are
the things that make a country
sustainable and and give it longevity
and and really they're the greatest
ideas we've ever had they were and they
were written down in the Declaration of
Independence in the Constitution so
these ideas of limited government and
local control right where we have a
diverse set of opinions and preferences
across this country and the only way to
maintain that without it boiling over is
is to give people local control okay
that's a very conservative answer that's
but basically what I'm talking about is
federalism right but I like to talk
about these things in ways that people
understand because if you just say
federalism and limited government a lot
of the liberals just turn off right
there that's just a conservative talking
point I don't want to hear it okay so we
have to boil this stuff down a little
bit better than I think we normally do
individual freedom and liberty personal
responsibility so these kind of cultural
values that that I think are important
to keep a society again together because
if people don't believe in personal
responsibility if you if you if you were
if you were more inclined to believe in
victimhood as opposed to personal
responsibility well well think about if
everybody did that and I just as I try
to explain to people what if what if
everyone thought that way how long would
we really last if nobody takes
responsibility least your first choice
isn't you have to take care of this and
then maybe it's her family and then it's
your community in your church and then
it's your local government then it's
your state and then it's the federal
government you know try to help people
understand that sort of line of
reasoning and white and why that's the
most and why that's the best way to run
a society you know other cultural values
I would actually throw out there are
mental toughness so a sense of grit a
sense of ability to this kind of just
American pioneer spirit that that I
think we're losing and you know this
kind of speaks to my whole history and
an outrage culture which I was which I
was a part of the SNL skit and and how
that all turned out and it was what I
was glad to be able to do was was was
just rebuff outrage culture on this idea
this you that you have to be offended
that
victim status is the greatest thing you
can accomplish and pointing out that
that's just not a healthy place for us
to go you know other other cultural
values I think are important you know
just basic notions of Liberty and also
how these things are interconnected you
can't have Liberty if you don't have a
personal responsible individual right
and you can't have pure Liberty if you
don't have people who are mentally tough
and able to compete in a free market all
of these things are intertwined so you
know to answer your question and in a
long-winded way it's you got to start
with the cultural aspects because
culture at your nose you as you always
say politics is downstream of culture
and the policy is downstream of politics
it's got to start with a culture then
you can get to the politics and we can
win and then we can actually put in the
policy that reflects those cultural
values that that give our society this
this longevity that we need so let's
talk about the culture for a second
because as I said the very top the way
that most folks know you is because of
the SNL situation so for folks who may
have missed that story and for folks who
may have not have seen it unfold maybe
you can tell us what that was like from
your perspective yeah well I mean I woke
up Sunday and all my friends were
texting me here's a head hey you made it
that's Adele it's a great job there and
then we see it you know and it doesn't
make me mad right away that's just I'm
from the SEAL Teams we have a very
different sense of humor okay pretty
thick-skinned folks mr. Pete Davidson
who is one of the stars of SNL made a
joke about your eye patch and suggested
that you were a pirate or that you were
some sort of James Bond villain yeah
it's up like that because the word that
was fine that wasn't even you know his
his comments weren't that bad it was it
was it was the part that maybe was
scripted maybe not and he just said oh
lost in war or whatever you know it was
an extremely dismissive thing wherever
but and that that's what made America
angry kind of brought us together
you know SNL was taking a lot of fire
for that and they came around to
emailing me an apology and then and then
eventually the producers called me and
said hey why don't we have you on this
weekend you can say whatever you want I
said well this week is Veterans Day
weekend I can't really go on I've got a
lot of events already planned they said
no it has to be Veterans Day weekend for
actly the reasons of you know because we
insulted veterans I said that's a good
point
so let's make it happen and then let's
make this a fun cool thing to do and I
think we did I mean a lot of fun doing
it yeah it really is pretty fantastic
for folks who haven't seen the segment
you should go on youtube and you should
check it out basically you did something
that was unique first of all you're a
comedy bit was was hilarious Dan goes
after the the Pete Davidson and makes
fun of his appearance and and the whole
point is obviously that we can make
jokes and that was what was unique it
was unique moments I said online I
thought it was maybe the most uplifting
moment in American politics I'd seen in
a decade because it was you sitting next
to him and actually empathizing with him
and saying listen we can get beyond the
outrage culture was something that I
thought was pretty unique yeah and it's
it's so important that we're able to
joke with each other again I think we've
really lost that you can just leave and
look in the news almost every single day
and find an example of this of where
we're just we're so ready to to pounce
all right we're publicans pounced right
so but it's not you know it and we've
got to be careful to not to be not to be
overly sensitive and for the most part I
think we're better about that but it
doesn't mean we're perfect and we don't
wanna be hypocrites either on this
particular issue but it's it's it's
really a shame I'm not sure how to fix
it except for to just not be part of the
problem and to you know encourage a
little light heartedness every every
once in a while but I mean jeez you saw
my joke about the Super Bowl
I like that just it's just when I was
like really this is what triggers people
it's amazing it's amazing anything
anything will trigger anybody in a
second I'm gonna ask you how you think
conservatives can do better in the call
chores and how you actually define the
culture wars as opposed to the political
wars but first when the founders crafted
the Constitution the first thing they
did was to make sacred the rights of the
individual to share their ideas without
limitation by their government the
second right they numerated was the
right of the population to protect that
speech and their own persons with force
you know how strongly I believe in these
principles I'm a gun owner owning a
rifle is an awesome responsibility
building rifles is no different Bravo
company manufacturing was started in a
garage by marine vet more than two
decades ago to build a
professional-grade product that meets
combat standards BCM believes the same
level of protection should be provide
to every American regardless of whether
they're a private citizen or a
professional BCM is not a sporting arms
company they design engineer and
manufacture life-saving equipment and
they assume every rifle leaving their
shop will be used in a life-or-death
situation by a responsible citizen a law
enforcement officer or soldier oversees
every components of a BCM rifle is hand
assembled and tested by Americans to a
life-saving standard BCM feels moral
responsibility as Americans to provide
tools that will not fail the user when
it's not just a paper target BCM works
with leading instructors in marksmanship
from top levels of America's Special Ops
forces from Marine Corps force
reconnaissance to US Special Ops forces
who can teach the skills necessary to
defend yourself your family or others to
learn more about Bravo company
manufacturing head on over to Bravo
Company MFG comm that's Bravo Company
MFG comm go check them out right now if
you need even more information you can
check them out at youtube.com slash
Bravo Company USA so we're talking about
the culture wars and again I said at the
time I've told members of the press that
I think one of the reasons that you've
become such a new fresh face of the
Republican Party so fresh so faith is
that you've actually engaged positively
and in an effective way in in the
culture wars how do you define the
culture wars and why do you think so
many conservatives particularly in
politics seem to miss the importance of
the cultural Wars generally yeah two
very important questions there so how do
we define the culture well this is
different the system there's different
battle lines drawn on the culture war so
I think examples are the best way to
talk about the cultural wars one example
I have courier in California recently
there was a lady I think she worked for
Santa Barbara Community College she was
she was upset that they no longer did
the Pledge of Allegiance before board
meetings or something along those lines
I think I'm getting the story right and
as she was testifying her story SH you
know what she got up into the Pledge of
Allegiance and she was she was met with
the most ferocious ferocious leftist
attacks and they were they were there in
the room just screaming at her shouting
her down and she's in tears as she's
given the Pledge of Allegiance that that
is a fundamental part of the culture war
this idea that either either you love
your country and we all agree on that or
you truly despise your country have not
you have contempt for it that that's
that's a I think that's the most
important part of the culture where this
idea of whether we love our country or
not that's what worries me
what I
I try to ask liberals is I mean you know
don't you think where on your
conservatives don't you think we
conservatives are on your side on this
don't we all love our country and don't
you realize that you're being sucked in
by the leftist here I mean there's you
always point out there's a there's quite
a difference between left ISM and
liberalism my worry is that liberalism
opens the gates to leftism right because
because it's not bad to be concerned
about income and income inequality it's
not bad to care about the poor it's not
bad to care about equal rights and
justice and all of these things that's
not even that's not a fundamentally bad
thing to do but but I what I what I want
liberals to understand is that it does
give way to these things it does give
way eventually if given free rein to
leftism the kind of things we see there
in the culture war you know I think
other aspects of the cultural war you
know I think you see it on campus all
the time you know whether free speech is
a fundamental right or not you know the
social justice movement as a whole and
those kind of battles I think I think
that I think that is more of a cultural
war issue sometimes less of a policy
issue no it does manifest in policy
sometimes but the other aspect of your
question is is how do politicians fight
it and and I do think it's important for
us to do that because it's what people
listen to and again politics is
downstream a culture you can't win in
politics until you've won the culture
war so you have to you have to engage on
that front you know you you have to
engage on on whether it's right to
appreciate the national anthem or not
because that again this idea of whether
we should contempt for our country or
not is an important it's important part
of our culture it's the one thing that
brings us together we have ideals that
bring us together we don't have skin
color we don't have religion you know
even even geography isn't a great thing
to bring people together you need ideas
you need fundamental values and I worry
greatly that those are being undermined
and I work greatly that politicians
aren't fighting on those on those fronts
enough so that's the benefit of going on
SNL that's the benefit of doing the
media that we that we do a sharing
yourself a little bit more with people
on social media
I don't think politicians do enough of
that I think they're a little too
careful we don't need to be so careful
all right but let's let you share
yourself with the people connect with
people let them know you're human let
them know the things you like to talk
about that maybe outside of politics
that would go a long way I think one of
the reasons the SNL moment went so viral
and I think it was hailed by people on
all sides is that I think the left was
was shocked that a Republican was a
human being and this this is sort of the
problem when you talk about liberalism
sliding into leftism all the things that
liberals talk about maybe with the
exception of income inequality because I
think the conservatives are more
concerned about their be the growth of
poverty than they are about some people
being rich and some people being poor
but all the other exactly but all the
other issues that you talk about those
are issues where conservatives are also
deeply engaged and the way that liberals
slide from being a liberal into a
leftist is by casting aspersions at
people on the other side and suggesting
we don't care about the same things
you're bad you're vile you're terrible
and so when you are honest I know and
suddenly you're a nice guy and not only
that you were being extraordinarily
generous with somebody who had
personally insulted you and then made an
offhand nasty remark about military
service I think that's why so many
people it was used dragging leftists
back from leftism and toward and sort of
liberalism the idea that we all still
have some things in common yeah I think
it's a good point I saw this trending on
Twitter the other day this I'm what I'm
the radical left you know and then and
then they'll have this explanation for
what that means and it's usually along
the lines if you know because I care
about the environment and I want
everybody have access to health care I
was like do you think you're the only
ones who want those things you know
don't demonize us in this terrible way
do you really think that the right
doesn't believe that I mean and I don't
know if it's if it's intellectual
dishonesty or if they've just really
have never spoken to a conservative
oftentimes I've just never spoken to a
conservative and I saw that at Harvard
quite a bit like right here's why I mean
they've never seen one like it's really
funny and they and they truly don't know
what we believe I've watched them try to
make arguments that they think that
we'll like you know the carbon dividend
is a great one a great example so this
this idea that that that you should be
you can have a carbon tax but you're
gonna distribute it so the government's
not making money therefore it's
conservative
like that's not what conservatism is you
want to create a whole new bureaucracy
to redistribute money how is that
efficient that's not that's not good
limited government and I and I would
tell these professors this so like you
do realize that you're not making the
right arguments towards conservatives
this is not the way to win our hearts
I'm just
letting you they really don't know what
we think they've never bothered to study
it which is strange because I think
there's a lot of history and framework
to conservatism what worries me about
progressivism
is its progress at any cost so it can go
anywhere there's no limits to this
there's there's no way to box that and
again that's why good-natured
well-intentioned liberalism eventually
leads to what is more dangerous which is
progressivism you know the Wilsonian
progressivism were they they openly have
contempt for the Constitution that
worries me there is no limit to that it
has power at all cost to do good things
well who decides good things well they
do whatever that might mean at the
moment and that changes over time and
we've seen we've seen the extrude I
think your average voter will say hey
both sides have just moved to the
extreme maybe that's true and it is true
as far as willingness cooperate
willingness to vote with the other side
and you can measure these things okay so
that that is true both sides have moved
to extremes on that but then we have the
question okay who is really moved to the
extreme on policy conservatives haven't
really okay now we know there's there's
the Trump administration is a little
different of course especially with
trade policy but for the most part
conservatives still believe what we
believe decades ago the left hasn't ever
the left has changed quite a bit the
border debate is a big example of that
right like you know again we don't have
to rehash all the speeches made by Chuck
Schumer and others you know being so
strong on border security and then doing
a 180 now I think they've gone they've
done more radically left on abortion
issues they've gone way more radically
left on economic issues if socialism is
no longer a dirty word why is that well
because progressivism has progressivism
has no limits that's a scary thing
that's what I want people to understand
that when they're voting they're voting
based on a governing philosophy that's
what you should be voting for you know
vote for issues if they're really
important to you but please vote on a
governing philosophy and and I think
conservatism is the right governing
philosophy it's it's what gave us
everything we have we should have some
gratitude for that progressivism is
something you don't know where it's
going and that should scare us so what
you have to deal with Democrats I'm sure
much more now in Congress than you had
to do in your home district so now
you're in Congress you're having to deal
with Democrats and what I've heard from
members of Congress members of the
Senate is a couple of different stories
one is that the
Kratts our true believers in this wild
progressive agenda that they actually
believe what it is that they're saying
and then I hear sometimes that no
Democrats actually behind closed doors
know that what they're saying is is
pretty wild and you know they're
catering to a base and if you actually
get them off the record then they're
quite willing to be moderate it's just
that once they get a camera on them all
of a sudden they move to the radical
left in order to please their base which
of you found to be more true or does it
sort of depend on the on the person it
depends on the person that I think I
think that's I think both are true it
does depend on the person what I find
there's a couple things I find actually
being behind the scenes on the border
debate specifically they agreed with us
a lot of them agreed with us but just
would never vote for us that was
extremely frustrating I found that to be
a deeply dishonest way to govern and I'm
still frustrated about and I'll continue
to fight those battles on Homeland
Security Committee so the border is a
pretty important thing to me on the
bigger issues and sort of the more the
more radical socialism Korea New Deal
type issues I have yet to talk about
that kind of stuff with a with a lot of
the more moderate Democrats what I see
from the more moderate ones which is
generally the ones I hang out with
they're they more what with their
tendency is is to is to cover for the
Socialists right they'll they'll dismiss
it as yeah yeah we know about all of
that but don't worry well what do you
mean don't worry you know it's this is
this is really gaining traction at a
certain point you have to recognize that
at the green New Deal is quite a few
co-sponsors most presidential candidates
want the green your dealer they they
advocate for the green New Deal
Beto's talking about tearing down walls
I've in El Paso with contrary to what
his mayor and his residents think and
say no I mean any backtrack on that I
was very proud of that by the way I was
able to was those my doing it I guess
both are true is the answer and I would
also say that I wish people understood
people actually get along better
behind closed doors than you would see
in public and it you know at the more we
can showcase that as members of Congress
I think the better for the American
people so specifically on the border
issues since you mentioned it a couple
of times do you think that there really
is a national emergency at the border or
is it just a slow rolling problem at the
border how should Americans view it
since you're obviously much more fluent
with those issues it's you know now
we're defining emergency very narrowly I
would say it's been an emergency
very long time and when you when you
have 400,000 people a year apprehended
crossing the border illegally that's a
pretty enormous number and Border Patrol
indicates to me that they've maybe catch
one in three and so you know you can
triple that number and that's and that's
the lowest in decades because Democrats
immediately come back at me and they'll
say we will well do would you agree
that's the lowest in decades yes is it
low no okay next question okay like you
know it doesn't matter you know what you
know it helps lower that well enforcing
the border all right putting putting
this bollard fencing where we need it
and I think we should continue to do
that and so is it an emergency
yes as the policy right yes is that is
the process the president is undertaking
the best one it's not the best one it's
not ideal
I think I think you can argue both ways
on that I am worried about the precedent
but maybe not as much as people should
be okay let me explain that a little bit
so what the president is doing is he's
appropriating money that wasn't given to
him to enforce a law that exists okay
and the law is you can't cross the
border okay so so that's very different
from say declaring a national emergency
on gun violence and then changing gun
laws right what was the equivalent of a
Democrat president doing that would
essentially be appropriating more money
to enforce the same laws that's not
really that bad so so I'm not so sure
that we need to worry that much about
the precedent we could also argue
constitutionally speaking the president
is there to faithfully execute the laws
written by Congress right that's what
that's literally what it says what are
the laws say they say you're not allowed
to cross the border again that that's
arguing both sides of it it's it's still
it's still not a great process and I
think it's going to get bogged down in
courts and that's my that's my biggest
frustration with it it's creating a lot
of political uncertainty probably won't
work and I I'd rather continue to fight
this in Congress because I think we
eventually started winning the messaging
battle I think we're losing that for a
long time I think we're using the wrong
arguments and letting Democrats use very
dishonest arguments instead of using
unassailable arguments again like that
400,000 number using unassailable
arguments and and then making them be
more honest about what they believe and
what they don't believe and the biggest
frustration
how all these negotiations went over the
last few weeks was that I no longer
believe the Democrats actually want
border security or enforcement and this
is based on what they were asking for in
those negotiations they'll give you some
examples when when Border Patrol is
asking for 5.7 billion dollars they're
there then what they're what they're
asking for is to fund their top eight
priorities and then that Budds those
priorities or geographic in nature
democrats wanted to say okay fine we'll
fund three of them and we're like oh
great one through three no no no six to
eight why on earth would you why what is
what could possibly be your reason
except you want less enforcement the
other thing they did was what was they
were dealers demanding that we that we
decrease the number of detention beds so
that's a decrease in our ability to
enforce there is no other reason for
that except you don't like enforcing
this law you don't like enforcing
illegal immigration you have reasons for
that I don't it's unclear what they are
but they're not good and then and then
they there was another provision snuck
in there which which essentially makes
it more likely that children will be
trafficked based on the you know I think
you've covered this before so I don't I
don't need to delve into it too much
more than maybe folks you've not heard
but yeah well well what this provision
says is that if you're a sponsor of a
child or a potential sponsor or a
potential sponsor in the household then
you can't be deported by ice so for an
accompanying minor who's crossed the
border well what does that mean in
practice what it means in practice is is
this when I was down at the border we
saw 16 kids this is just one day I was I
was with Border Patrol they had 16 kids
who are identified who who came with
adults who were not their parents
further questioning they found a stash
house in Houston with about 54 illegal
immigrants in it why were the 54 people
in a house well because the drug cartels
would not let them leave all right
because because they were being
trafficked and because they hadn't paid
their dues yet drug cartels have
complete operational control of the
southern border on the Mexico side
Mexican government has no say and how
that works
the illegal immigrants do not come
across by themselves that does not
happen they have to pay somebody and and
and and this is enforced violently
because it's a business for them right
they lose money if they don't allow this
to be enforced so that's what people
need to understand about it those are
the right arguments and we're we can win
those arguments if we say them
enough and say it with honesty don't
overstate our point
you always get slammed if you ever state
your point right so that's what I try to
do on the border debate so I want to ask
you about the budget committee and you
work there before I get to that I do
want to ask you about again it must be
tough to be in Congress it's a rough job
and it's a rough job because number one
you have to deal with people you
disagree with all the time who are
sometimes being honest sometimes being
dishonest and the other fact is that you
get a lot of flack from the outside and
I found myself you know really thinking
a lot more in recent years about as
influences grown about how to wield that
influence when it comes to members of
Congress because there is a tendency to
call for people's heads if they don't do
exactly what you want and that's I think
unfair to a lot of politicians
leave us alone that it does happen so I
haven't been in politics that long I
haven't dealt with this very much but I
certainly see it I see how it can work
there and there's there's really two
separate movements in the conservative
movement that that do this right they're
sort of the more there's the more
Puritan conservatives again people I
pretty much agree with on just about
everything but they don't want you to
vote any other way they don't want you
to make any deals they want to touch
down they don't want you to move the
ball forward a few yards it's not
acceptable
that's what hurt us by the way I think
in the last couple years with health
care and with and with the border issues
so that's a problem you know you've got
to let us work and you've got to
understand too that these politicians
aren't selling out to the swamp
whatever that means Oh's asking what
does that mean and nobody can tell me
like I don't know what it means to
sellouts okay the reality is is that
most members of Congress are well
they're catering to somebody yes but
it's their constituents because that's
the people who vote the men you know so
it's not as it's this this idea of it
this beings this corrupt place that's
it's just not entirely true it's not
what I've seen I'm not saying it can't
happen I'm just saying I haven't really
seen it the the other the other the
other element of of what we deal with is
this need to support the president no
matter what and again I support the
president on pretty much everything
there's there's a couple things I
disagree with and I'm very open about
that you said a piece in The Wall Street
Journal about this about how much I
disagree with pulling out of Syria and I
disagree with the trade policy cuz it's
bad for my district so that's fine
that's fine
frankly he's fine with it he understands
that you know it's I think as time has
gone on to he's gonna grow more
comfortable in the executive position
and I think we can openly disagree about
these things but uh but there's
certainly a sense even among my voters
and they'll say you know we just get
this sense that the Republicans just
aren't supporting the president and I'm
like why why do you think that you know
wouldn't Mitch McConnell do to you he
held up the process for the Supreme
Court nominees for for you know he got
you Neal Gore's chick he got you Bret
cabin out like what what did he do to
you that you're so mad about he would it
he would not allow a spending bill on
the floor until the president said he
would sign it I mean what what did what
did Mitch McConnell do that it's so bad
and I get that they don't do everything
perfectly I'll tell you I fully agree
but but we have we have to be a little
more careful with eating our own it's
it's not exactly what you think and this
is and this goes back to remember my
cultural values of mental toughness and
discipline part of that is is always
stopping counting to ten and saying is
there more to this story is there more
to this story can I breathe can I
breathe and have the mental fortitude to
say there might be more to this than I
think I want to dig for a second on the
issue of the swamp so you mentioned the
swamp and I agree with the idea that
it's not that Congress people are being
randomly paid off by evil corporate pay
masters who smoke cigars and look like
me but in any case that seems to be a
prevailing myth that everybody in
Congress just wants to go to cocktail
parties and I've never been to one of
these cocktail parties they're supposed
to be unbelievable
I keep hearing about these amazing
cocktail parties frankly sitting with a
bunch of Congress people having
cocktails sounds about like the worst
evening I could ever possibly have fun
cocktail parties and if there are I
haven't been daddy it's yeah I mean
there's lobbyists you get to know them
sure you're with other members of
Congress but there's it's just not what
people think it is
it's how does that speak to campaign
finance so AOC I know was getting a lot
of attention because she did a
questioning on campaign finance where
she basically suggested that anyone who
takes any sort of lobbyist money is in
the pocket of the lobbyists it's always
seemed to me having dealt with at this
point you know probably almost a hundred
members of Congress that what actually
happens is lobbyists tend to find people
who already support their agenda and
then they contribute to their campaigns
because they like to see those people in
Congress but
where do you come down on the campaign
finance yeah well you know first of all
there it seems like they're they're fine
with a very transparent corporate PAC
money or they're sorry they're not fine
with that which is very transparent but
they're totally fine with that blue
which is extremely hard to to to find
the origin of you know and that's and so
I don't I don't see how you can you you
can balance those two ideas but they do
there so here's what corporate PAC is
first of all it's a bunch of people who
work for a corporation who pull their
money together and then donate okay and
the max second donor is $5,000 alright
so can I be bought off with $5,000
answer's no I think it's just it's very
simple no and you're absolutely right
they they only come to you if they
already agree with you and then you know
that we might have more detailed
discussions on okay like what are we you
know what issues do you guys care about
can I get behind that no yes maybe
probably not you know that that's it's a
very it's a very simple conversation but
the reality is is they just don't wield
the power that people think they do they
they bring up issues that you never
would heard of otherwise and I don't I
don't fundamentally see a problem with
that it's it's very it's this is a very
strange attack on on corporations and
again this because this goes back to the
culture wars right like do we want to
punish success do we do believe in
socialism really believe in the free
market all of this stuff can always be
traced back to the culture or it has
always puzzled me the idea that money is
in complete control of American politics
and that if the NRI science' checks
because they bought somebody if that was
the case don't you think the NRA would
just go bribe every Democrat and then we
could get it right or the or that near
all pro-choice America would come bribe
every Republican I want to get to your
work on the budget committee so you said
you campaigned on entitlement reform
that's an amazing thing I wonder is that
ever going to happen because you know I
look at the situation people love their
entitlements two-thirds of the American
budget every year constitutes
entitlement spending and mandatory it's
not discretionary spending do you ever
see a future where there's a
restructuring of entitlements are we
gonna go the way of Europe and basically
we'll have an economic meltdown and then
we'll have to take austerity measures
well Medicare goes insolvent in 2026 and
Social Security goes insolvent 2034 I I
really hope we deal with it before that
because
here's what that means we know when
social security for instance goes
insolvent that means that benefits
automatically get cut that's what
happens according to current law well
what's instead gonna happen because
we're not actually gonna cut benefits to
seniors who are relying on those things
well they're gonna tax us they're gonna
tax my generation your generation and
they're gonna taxed us pretty heavily
and we're gonna be told that it'll be
fine for a little while they're gonna
have to tax us more okay this is a
completely unsustainable program now but
the question is are we gonna fix it well
I'd like to I'm gonna keep fighting to
fix it
Democrats have no interest in fixing it
that that's that's a real problem they
again we fundamentally disagree on why
there's a debt that's a real problem we
fundamentally disagree on the facts and
that's what I get out of these budget
hearings Democrats honestly believe that
history began two years ago with
President Trump and history began with
the tax cuts and they will actually
argue that the reason we have bad
deficits is because of these tax cuts
okay well let's look at the numbers on
this without without the tax cuts in
about ten years we'd have around thirty
two trillion dollars in debt with the
tax cuts we have about thirty three
trillion dollars in debt daily arca
those are not causing the debt I mean it
this is real simple numerical some
numerical evidence that we can look at
to prove that but they believe it and
they'll hammer that and they'll hammer
that and we'll say listen seventy
percent of spending is is mandatory
spending that's Social Security Medicare
Medicaid interest on the debt some other
entitlement programs as well things we
can't control things we refuse to vote
on and that's a real problem and that's
that's the issue okay how can we get to
a point where we actually vote on these
programs because the thing we fight
about constantly every year and again
going back to like what we're held
accountable for by these by conservative
groups is thirty percent of the budget
that's that's you know we're fighting
and it's worth fighting over don't get
me wrong but that's not what's causing
our future thirty three trillion dollar
debt it's mandatory spending it's
increasing health care costs and it's a
completely unsustainable Social Security
system and again I think we can reach
out to younger people our age and get
them to vote Republican based on this
issue and I'll just be very honest with
them when I talk about it say listen we
have to raise our retirement age we're
living longer we have to I shouldn't be
retiring at 67 I would like to I think
that would be great I want to live in
this utopia
it was talking about but it just can't
happen so let's actually make the hard
decisions again back to the culture what
are we willing to have the mental
fortitude and personal responsibility to
make the hard decision so that we can
live in a sustainable society a society
that has longevity that's what it always
comes down to that's connecting the
policy with the culture but you've got
to get the culture right first one of
the things that's been obviously
disappointing to watch is the newfound
embrace by the radical left and many
young people of socialism full-scale
they call democratic socialism now which
is I guess a soft version of socialism
or use capitalist infrastructure and
then build a bunch of socialist
institutions on top of it what why do
you think the newfound warmth for
socialism in a time where capitalism has
essentially cured extreme human poverty
where free markets have generated the
capacity to literally buy any top
anything and have it at your door in two
days thanks to thanks to Jeff B's host
and Amazon so why do you think so many
young people are buying into the lies of
socialism well it's a complete lack of
gratitude you know and I steal this idea
from general Goldberg in his book he
really talks about this a lot but I
think I think it really opens up the
truth here so there's there's a complete
lack of gratitude for these principles
that gave us all of these things and
again those principles is kind of I
think those cultural narratives and I
always hit back on these personal
responsibility this idea that liberty is
good okay that this idea of fairness
where where you get what you deserve not
that everybody gets equal stuff okay
that leads to the free market that leads
to the ability to thrive in a three free
market and that leads to prosperity and
we have all this proof that this
prosperity exists based on these
principles and yet there's no gratitude
for them right it's every generation
sort of wakes up and thinks it knows so
much better than the last generation and
and this one is unique because if I
think for two reasons one one we this
generation was coddled a lot by the by
the previous generation like you know no
longer allowed to play on playgrounds
told you that that you know second place
trophies all that right there's this
whole kind of change in culture and then
on top of that on top of that they have
the Internet so the Internet makes you
more knowledgeable but it doesn't
necessarily make you smarter and it
doesn't teach you the framework in which
to absorb those new ideas that you can
that you have at your fingertips so
that's an interesting combination
because it's it's it it means that
they're very confident in their ability
to say what they want that their
feelings matter most and that they can
kind of pick what ideas they want to use
there so I think that what we're from
the internet and that results in this
lack of gratitude
all right results in the situation where
it's like okay the idea of you're
walking through a forest and you see a
fence why is the fence there you know a
conservative might say well there might
be good reason that there's this fence
here there's land mines on the other
side and I don't like land mines as you
know so because but I think this new
generation somebody on the Left he
thinks they're smarter than everybody
else it's a there's obviously there's no
reason they said just obviously there's
no reason for this fence I mean we're
not even gonna question it doesn't make
any sense well maybe there is all right
maybe we should find out you know maybe
we should we should we should be a
little more responsible in our
policymaking as we move forward do you
think that unity is possible in the
country that's part of your optimistic
or pessimistic about the country coming
together again because in some ways it
seems like there's sort of moments of
optimism your SNL appearance and then
there are vast swaths of desert where
people are just clubbing each other like
it's Mad Max I mean what well where do
you stand on on being positive or
negative about the country which feels
at many points like it's coming apart oh
that's a good question and it's it's
very difficult to answer I I'm not
overly optimistic I'm not overly
pessimistic I I think I think our
country has seen worse before people
don't realize that a lot is looking at
history that that being said that being
said it's it's hard to see a way out of
it and you know I would just ask them
where people stopped being part of the
problem stop looking for reasons to club
and and that that would be nice and I
have to pull myself back from that
sometimes you know and the the standard
I try to give myself is attack ideas
don't don't be afraid to attack ideas
even make fun of ideas but but but try
not to question the character of the
others that that would be a good next
move and something I hope we can aspire
to and as conservatives I think we're
the character are our characters
questions in immense ways and I would
like to see a stop to that but at the
same time we shouldn't do it to the
other side
we've got a refrain at those moments but
uh I would say I would say instead of
being neutral I'm more optimistic than I
am pessimistic but we got a lot of work
to do
all right so I want to ask you about
your foreign policy about Syria and all
that first I read a piece where you were
talking about your thoughts on campaign
finance reform and campaign finance
limits and I was wondering if you might
explicate that sure sure so we were
talking about the corporate PAC money
side but there's another aspect to that
which is what should the limit being and
how arbitrary is that and what it what I
don't think a lot of people understand
and a lot of people who are railing
against corporate PAC money rarely gets
money in politics I don't really know
what that means
well well here's the actual reality
somebody like me who's got no
independent wealth I've got I've got no
political connections and I want to get
into politics okay so how does that
happen well it doesn't happen very
easily because there's something called
campaign contribution limits so you can
only take a certain amount of money and
it's it's not that big you can go up
against somebody who can self-fund their
own campaign so in my primary there was
one candidate and this is just one out
of nine they all had a lot of money but
one had six and a half million dollars
to spend on our campaign that's
impossible to compete with so you've
created a system by over-regulation and
by limiting campaign contributions
you've created a system where only the
rich and the well-connected can actually
compete again you could this philosophy
carries on it's a broader government
regulation on on businesses and the
economy at large
there also matters and campaign finance
and I don't think a lot of people
understand that okay so now I want to
get to your foreign policy so obviously
your military experience is defining
characteristic for you and you've been
watching the the Trump foreign policy I
have a group with large swaths of from
foreign policy there are a couple areas
where I have significant disagreements I
sense that you share some of those
disagreements one of them is pulling out
American troops from Syria where are you
on that and and why yeah I say don't do
it at least don't do it in a in a quick
manner and I say very simply to people
who question this and both the right and
the left questions this and I say listen
we go there so they don't come here it's
really that simple the world is a very
small place you can you can hop on a
12-hour flight you can be here or you
can get here even faster with the
movement of the internet and you can
radicalize people remotely can we saw
that in Orlando is
that San Bernadino we see it in Paris
that this happens when you give
terrorists like Isis the the space to
operate they will act on that they don't
they're not satisfied with what they
have there what they really want is to
take down Western civilization I know
this because they talk about it all the
time like we don't have to guess you
know I don't think guess what their
intentions are the same with Afghanistan
American leadership matters a lot more
so than people realize and we've
actually found the right balance and
this is what I tell the president he's
actually found the right balance here
between you know you know massive
amounts of troops and and and really
ill-advised pull outs like the one that
had happened in 2011 under Barack Obama
and Iraq neither of those are good well
President Trump has is a is a small
contingent relatively cheap in terms of
costs and it's the right move it allows
us to have eyes and ears on the ground
so that we can predict future attacks is
our intelligence collection side of it
allows us to build capacity within our
partner forces whether that's the Kurds
in Syria the Syrian democratic forces or
in Afghanistan the the Afghan government
they're not ready and when we risk those
being toppled and we risk a lot of
sacrifices being made in vain and I
really don't want to see that you know
they're not that I care about my I'm
still very you know that's fine
there's a lot of friends who have made
the ultimate sacrifice and that's you
know and and and if they could be here
right now they'd go right back just like
I would this is one of the issues that I
have with how politicians generally talk
about foreign policy and we are not
talking and that is that they just lie
about the expectations and foreign
policy this idea that well there's gonna
be a ringing victory in Iraq or
Afghanistan or Syria and then they'll
bring the troops home that'll be a big
ticker tape parade that hasn't happened
since World War two and there we were
fighting an actual government with
uniformed soldiers it was not a war on
terrorism yeah the the fact is that
low-level conflicts like Afghanistan or
like Syria and I mean by that is not
hundreds of thousands of troops in
simultaneous combat the the reality is
that a holding pattern may in fact be
the best that we can do in many of these
cases and yet no politician actually
wants to say that it's an insurance
policy right it's an insurance policy
against future attacks and what we hit
on is the definition of mission success
that that's that that's really the point
you are making I think which is
do we define mission success and
politicians has not been honest about
what mission success is maybe they don't
understand that the problem well enough
to define it for the American people
American people you know they're willing
to listen if we have leaders who are
willing to talk to them in honest ways
and they can tell alright and and so I
don't defy missions that you can't
define mission success in this case as
beating a a well-defined group in a
territory right so just kind of your
your typical warfare where there's
there's you know people wearing uniforms
and such you know there's no head of
state to to negotiate with here this is
different this is an ideology that
you're battling and it requires presence
in order to battle it and it requires
building capacity amongst your partners
and mission success is actually every
day that we don't have another 9/11
that's mission success and I think
that's what politicians need to be more
honest about so you've been dealing with
with President Trump is everybody has he
sort of become the star around which all
politics apparently revolves if you had
to grade the President on his
performance so far how would you grade
him well pretty I grade them pretty high
as far as policymaking goes as you know
again there's only a couple things I
really disagree with and that's the
pullout from here in Afghanistan and a
lot of his trade policy and and and not
that I don't see and understand where
he's trying to go with his trade policy
it just hurts my district that that's
the reality it's not workable for my
constituents but overall pretty good you
know I don't know about it grade I don't
like grading things but I would say
overall pretty good I like how opening
is to two members of Congress you know
he does listen it's a very open White
House and I think the heading should I
think he should get some some accolades
for that unfortunately I think again I'm
still pretty passionate about the border
issue I think he's absolutely right on
the border issue and I think but I do
think we could have done a lot better
job as a whole a lot better job
negotiating that and a lot better job
messaging that and the fights not over
though so we still have a chance to come
back from that so for people who are
skeptical about Congress particularly
among Republicans the Republicans
basically have a theme which is when
Democrats are in charge we stop them and
then when we
in charge then Republicans pass a tax
cut and that's pretty much what we do so
what would you say to people who watch
Republican Congress and they're
constantly disappointed by you know all
the promises to defund Planned
Parenthood to end Obamacare to secure
the border people who look at president
border struggling with with the border
now and say where were you in 2017 like
why wasn't this the top issue in 2017
why are we doing this now the Democrats
have taken over over Congress what would
you say to folks are we are we getting
it right when we criticize Congress are
we getting it wrong a lot of those
criticisms I I think are correct yes and
no so that on the border deal
specifically yes we should we should we
should have some self-critique there we
could have done better I wasn't there so
you know not my fault but it was m'as
goes back to this idea if you try are
you trying to do a Hail Mary or you're
trying to have a win and boy I think
every Republican would go back to those
deals being made right now and just and
and and absolutely make those deals that
were that were going on back then
there's a lot of inside baseball there
that even I don't really understand just
again because I wasn't there but it's
but it's very frustrating to voters
because and I think here's why because a
lot of politicians that go into office
and I think they over promise I think
they forget to inform people that you
need 60 votes in the Senate for a lot of
things right and they and so a lot of
people don't realize things like that so
they so they go in thinking well you
have a majority so what's the problem
get it done you have a majority and
you're all supposed to be exactly the
same - well first of all not all
Republicans are the same they cater to
different bases okay I can be pretty
conservative I am pretty conservative
that's just how all votes but I I have
to be understanding of some of the
Republicans who don't have those kind of
districts and they and in the end
they're not selling out to anybody
except their own constituents which is
kind of the whole point of
representative democracy so you know I I
want voters to be able to understand
that understand that I will fight for
the things I said I was going to fight
for I also try not to over promise
things that I just can't get done and
again when you campaign it's up to you
is a good politician to just be more
honest with your voters about what's
realistic and what's not and they can
take it again they can take some honesty
and some authentic
it's okay not to be so cagey and
programmed all the time and uh and I
think I was rewarded for it and so we'll
keep doing that so now I have to ask you
a weird personal questions so you
brought your wife along here today and
how did you how did you guys meet
so we met through a friend in San Diego
I had just come out there to start buds
and actually I just broken my leg my
first time through hell week and then I
was friends with with another girl who
was in the Navy and she went to they
were both Navy brats and they went to
middle school together and they
introduced us so here we are how long
did you guys date before he got married
she's how long do we date seven years oh
wow yeah what took you so long dude we
got married in 2013 so what are your
future aspirations so you obviously have
raised your profile more than any other
member of Republican Congress since your
election um you've only been in Congress
for about five minutes here but what are
your future aspirations on the
Republican side first we got to do right
by our district that's that's always the
very first thing before you start
thinking bigger than that politics is
often about opportunities more so than a
than a very well-defined pipeline upward
so you know as you can probably imagine
as you well know I think the
opportunities that come to you I maybe
maybe you run for Senate one day maybe
run for governor maybe you stay in the
house and try to go to a leadership
position well these days everybody runs
for president so who knows but for right
now I'm young I can be patient I don't I
don't have to leave my constituents and
and and try to move on to something
bigger right now I want to do right by
them and there's there's some there's
local issues that matter to them that I
thought I think we have to fight for
before we start believing that we're
worthy of something bigger
how have you been treated by the media
after the SNL thing obviously there's a
lot of warm media coverage my experience
with the media has been every time
there's a bit of warm media coverage is
immediately followed by a piano being
dropped from a high story
in your experience with the media since
the SNL stuff yeah it's not terrible but
it's not great either you know depends
on which parts of the media of course
it's a conservative media I'm still you
know we're still friends and that's good
I like to keep it that way and I think
you're more mainstream media hasn't hit
me hard in any way new you're CNN's even
here MSNBC me Morning Joe had me on
wasn't you know they didn't they didn't
they didn't try to you know give me a
right hook or anything it was it was
okay you know but then but then you do
something like make a joke about the
Super Bowl and you joke about the 70
percent tax rate oh boy they will come
after you it like that was the funniest
thing yeah that that was an absurd thing
for people who missed it AOC tweeted
something out about well she'd been
suggesting a seventy percent tax rate
from people making above ten million
dollars and after New England won the
Super Bowl Dan tweeted out that the the
New England should redistribute it's
it's points are in Super Bowls detects
the Patriots a seventy percent to make
the NFL more fair and equal right then
she tried to explain why the the joke
went completely over her which which
seems to happen a lot I mean which is
which is amazing for a woman is
brilliant and well informed such a
strange thing that all the things that I
thought would trigger the left I mean
that one wow you can't joke can't joke
anymore well this is this is one of the
things that I think has made you popular
and I think it's one of the things that
the left can't handle is that you do
have a sense of humor you are
good-natured what they actually want in
Republicans is people who look mean who
look nasty and who are going to get
angry at every single problem here that
well that well that that's a good point
to touch on actually they they do want
us to be old like us that's what they
want they they targeted our our female
candidates in this last election heavily
you know young Kim in California Mia
love was targeted heavily Katy Arrington
out in South Carolina so you know they
they they they don't want us to be
anything else but but old white guys and
that that's a problem it's a problem for
us we need to identify that we should we
should be more diverse Lynne because
it's it's hopeful to our message if we
have different kinds of people messaging
it and I think that's important again
you know we don't like identity
politics and ideas matter much more than
that but we're foolish if we think that
it's not beneficial to have more people
on our side more different eyes people
feel male/female you know different
races all of it we have to and I think
you know and I think that be to our
benefit but Democrats certainly don't
want that they don't want us to be funny
they don't want to be good people and
they'll they'll they'll hit you and very
care and interesting ways as I've
noticed and some of the local media has
done similar similar ways they I don't
call it fake news but I do call it
deliberately misleading news where
they're reporting facts but it's facts
that are very clearly meant to mislead
the public in a certain direction and
and that's just unfortunate and you
bring this up to a lot of journalists
and they'll be so indignant about it
like how could you possibly say that how
could you that we are the press as the
figure they put themselves on this
pedestal that is really it's really
unbelievable and I don't quite
understand I don't know you're part of
the press maybe so in a second I want to
ask you one final question I want to ask
you about what you think is the biggest
problem facing America that's solvable
some of these things may be intractable
what do you think is the biggest
solvable problem facing the country I'm
going to ask that question to
representative Dan Crenshaw but to hear
his answer you actually have to be a
daily wire subscribers to subscribe head
on over to daily wire comm click
subscribe you can hear the end of our
conversation over there
Oh congressman Crenshaw thanks so much
for stopping by I really appreciate your
time and thanks for all you're doing and
thanks for all you have done really
appreciate it's awesome to be here been
a big fan so this was a pretty cool
honor it thanks a lot thanks
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis Glover edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Dylan case hair
and makeup is by Joshua alvera title
graphics by Cynthia and hula the Ben
Shapiro shows Sunday special is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
[Music]